وانا احييكم الى التفاصيل في اوكرانيا
هناك ايجابيات وتكتيكات جديده يسعى من
خلالها الرئيس بوتل لتجنب الانقسامات التي
يمكن ان تحدث في صفوف المقاتلين في
الميدان العمليات العسكريه تصبح تابعه
لقياده الاركان الروسيه مباشره والجميع
سيصبح خاضعا لقائد الاركان فاليري جيري
سيموف الذي عينه بوتين يحل محل سيرجي الذي
اصبح نائبا مكلفا فقط تحرك جديد من طرف
مدينه
عسكريه
لجيوش مختلفه تحت لواء واحده
ايضا فرق المتطوعين في حين يرى البعض
الاخر ان خطوه بوتين جاءت نتيجه مخاوف
كبيره من احتماليه
تصدعات ولتجنب اي انتكاسات المحتمله بين
القوات الموجوده في شرق وجنوب الولاده
خصوصا ان قائد اعتبركنر وجه انتقادات
كبيره للجيش الروسي وقال ان قوته هي من
قامت بتحرير بلده سوليدار لوحدها غير ان
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت ان قرار
الاستبدال يهدف الى تحسين جوده وفعاليه
اداره القوه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع معاه ضيوفنا من موسكو
تيمور دويدار الخبير في قطاع الاعمال
والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا بيك ومن كيف بعد
قليل كذلك سيلتحق بنا اوراغ رمضان او حاضر
معنا الان رئيس مركز الاوراس للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اهلا بكمين اسم حالي ان ابدا
من كيف طالما صرت جاهز سيد همم
رمضان
لابدا في الواقع بتعليقات الاوكرانيين
بخصوص هذا التغيير الثالث لقائد العمليات
العسكريه في كيف يقولوا الاوكران بان هذا
التغيير يدل على فشل همم وصعوبه العمليه
العسكريه لماذا
طبعا عندما يكون التغيير بهذه الطريقه
ونعرف ان القياده العسكريه في روسيا تم
تغييرها يعني اكثر من ثلاث مرات يعني
بخصوص تعيين القائد على القوات المسلحه
وكذلك عندما يخص التغيير اعلى هيئه وهي
الاركان العليا او قياده الاركان للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه هذا يعني ان هناك خلل
نظامي في تسيير العمليه العسكريه
حسب القاموس الروسي لان تركيب
اصبح الان
نائبا ليه رئيس الاركان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه في توقيت عصيب يعني رغم كل ما
يروج بخصوص التقدم الحديث القوات المسلحه
لمحور سوليدار لكن نعرف ان الروس يفقدون
يوميا يعني المئات من الارواح وكذلك في
العتاد والقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
بمقاومه شرسه يعني لن تقدم ما يريده
الاعلام الروسي وما تريده الروسيه ولذلك
فهذا التغير بشكل متناغم ومتزامن مع
العمليات العسكريه القائمه الان في
الجمباز هذا يعني ان هناك خل النظامي في
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه هناك مثل روسي انه
لا نغير الاحصنه ونحن يعني في الاستراحه
يعني يجب ان نواصل مع نفسه الاحصنه فقط
هذا مثال
رمضان اذا كان الحصان رابح ولكن خلينا
ناخذ راي همم
الموضوع هل هناك خلل تنظيمي خلل استراتيجي
خلل في اداره هذه العمليات العسكريه كما
يرى السيد اوراق سيد بادار
وللمشاهدين
شقاينا اعتقد دون الدخول في المسائل
العسكريه
امم الشرق الاول همم
لاحظنا انتقادات كثيره
همم
تحركات القوات همم تبع وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وكان هناك جدال واسع حتى وزع اعلاميه في
الدخل الروسي وخارجها بهذا الصدد
يعني لاحظنا ان هناك احتكاك بين همم
القوات همم من المرتزقه همم
والقائل له على القوات النظاميه
فراينا ان هناك
فربما لهذا الغرض تم همم يعني
وكان هناك هجوم ايضا على رئيس الاركان من
قبل القوات المرتزقه تبع بريوجل
وربما لهذا الغرض همم
هذه القراءه هل تشير الى ان ريكوجين او
فقط هذا التفصيل لانك تقول بان وكان هناك
صراع داخلي بين الجيش النظامي وبين القوات
المرتزقه نتحدث عن قوه فاجنر لان كويت
فاجنر كذلك اتهمت الجيش الروسي بانه همم
خاصه في ما يخص بخموت لن اتحدث عن خيرسون
او عن مناطق اخرى ولكن في بخموط كانت هناك
انتقادات قوه فاجنر للجيش النظامي الروسي
هل ترى دقه في هذه الاتهامات او هناك
حسابات داخليه اكثر منها
اعتقد حسابات ربما لحتى رئيس الداخليه
ربما حسابات يعني تخيل المراه ان هو ركب
من السماء
لا هناك لا نستطيع حتى ان نقارن امم
قواتها ومقدرتها
وقدراتها مع الجيش الروسي النظام الذي حتى
الان لم يستخدم في اوكرانيا بكامل طاقته
لكن الشق الاخر الذي اردت ان اوجه لك له
نظركم همم ربما هناك همم تحول في همم
الرؤيا لهذه العمليه العسكريه التي تسمى
في روسيا رسميه عمليه عسكريه محدوده اه في
اوكرانيا وتطرق الى
القياده همم الكامله انت ذكرت ان ذلك ثالث
بانوا مع بدايه هذه العمليه العسكريه كان
هناك تكتم على اسم القائد فيما بعد جاء
القائد همم
سورو فيكيين همم بقي ثلاثه اشهر والان تم
تغييره الى القائد دراسي موف
من المصدر سيدتي التدخل في اوكرانيا حصل
من ثلاث محاور وكل محور كان له القائد
تبعه همم القائد همم
له المنطقه التي كانت المنطقه العسكريه
التي كانت همم
يعني المنطقه الغربيه المنطقه الجنوبيه
مثل اللواء
الابيض همم
كانوا همم بالطبعه كان هناك تنسيق لكن كل
واحد منهم كان يرى القياده همم بقياده
ويجيرها همم
طبعا لا اريد الخوف في ذلك همم تم تعيين
صوره كده همم همم انما ما يتداره اداره
متكامله اصبحت ان تحدث في همم في همم تلك
المعارك الان تم اعطاء همم القياده العليا
وهو الغريب لان القيد العليا كانت ما زلت
في اا رئاسه الاركان ووزاره الدفاع بالطبع
ف- اا المرتبه الاولى الان اعطت ليم همم
السيد دراسي همم الذي هو رئيس الاركان
والذي لم يعني هو كان باستمرار متصل فيه
هذه العمليه منذ بدايتها ولكن خليني ابقى
معك كلمه ليس من مهندسين لا لا هناك
مبالغه في القول ذلك
انا قلت
انا
ما اقدر عده سنين في الداخل
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه فلا ادري من هو
المهندس صراحه لان ذلك المهندس ان كان
فعلا مهندس لكن استطاع همم
السيطره في همم باقه ورد تطرح مجموعه من
الاستفهامات سيد ويدار ولكن على الاقل
تقيم هذا التغيير بالقول بان هناك رؤيه
جديده هل ترى سيد رمضان بان هناك رؤيه
روسيه جديده
للتقدم بهذه العمليه العسكريه وما مدى
نجاحت هذه الرؤيه الجديده ما مدى قدرتها
على همم فصل الموضوع
فرقه ليس هناك جديد الروس يذهبون باستعمال
التعداد
للقوات الحيه وهذا ياتي في اطار ما يعرف
بالتعبئه الجزئيه وكذلك اتت نماذج من
التسليح الروسي الثقيل لان روسيا منذ
البدايه كانت تتصور المساله خلال سريع او
شهر ولذلك كانت عمليه عسكريه خاصه
لحرف الشمال الاطلسي في هذه المرحله على
روسيا ذهب الروسي باستعمال
القوه العسكريه مباشره
يتوافق ويتناغم مع القوه الجويه الروسيه
فهذه ليست يعني في مرحله جديده هي مواصله
لما سبق يعني روسيا تريد ان تسيطر على
اقليم جمباز كليه لان سمعنا بوتين منذ
اكثر من شهرين اكد في كلامه نحن العمليه
ما يسمى حمايه الضم باس وهذا اصبح مصطلح
جديد مرادف لما يعرف بالعمليه العسكريه
الروس الان يحذرون لهجوم حسب ما نفهم
انطلاقا من هذه العمليات باستعمال عامل
الشتاء تما يقولون القائد القائد الشتاء
الشتوي وقائد سيراميك الذي
ارمجدون ولكن للاسف الشديد
لدرجه الحراره في هذا الشتاء او في هذا
الموسم ليست بما يريدونه يعني الى حد الان
الشتاء لم يكن
له روسيا للاتحاديه
فالاجابه على السؤال فنحن نتوقع ان الروس
يحاولون السيطره على مدينه
طبعا من اجل الانتقال للوصول الى اكرمه
تورسكوا سلابيانس يعني ستكون هذه كذلك
عباره عن عمليه
طويله المدى طويله النفس لان في حين ستصل
المعدات الغربيه من ال- اا كما تعرفون ان
هناك دعم بالدبابات الثقيله مثلا التي
همم
بدات تصل الى
الجبهات الاخرانيه وكذلك كان منظومه قاتل
منظمات اخرى فاظن ولو في حال السيطره على
باك هذا لن يعطي النتيجه التي يريدها
الروس فهو بس يغصون في المستنقع كرمتوس
وصله ليانس ولن تتم عمليه تحرير بن باز
اظن في السنه القادمه يعني قبل الشتاء اذا
حقيقه
اعتبرها معركه مهمه في دار هل معركه بخمض
خاصه وان قائد فاجنر في وصفه لطريقه
الاقتتال في داخل يقول بانه كل بيت وكانه
قلعه محصنه هل معركه بخمه هي التي دفعت
بهذه التغيرات العسكريه تعتقد
الخطوط الدفاعيه
الاوكرانيه معموله
تجهيزات هندسيه ذكيه في كل المدن في كل
مواقع الدفاع
التحصينات الخرسانيه
والمنشات الهندسيه الدفاعيه معروفه هناك
انتقادات في روسيا لماذا يتم
مهاجمه
راسا
في هذه المدينه وفقدان كثير من همم من
العسكريين همم
ليس لديه تعليق يعني على ذلك ولكن كسر
عظام في
في ما نشاهده
شخصيه لا ارى اي جدوى من اطاله هذه
الماساه انا اعتبرها ماساه مثل ناس كثيرين
هذه مثلا
سياسيه همم
اللي كان فليتم السيطره لكن
بطرق يعني يعني كان هناك وسائل على مدار
سنين
للسيطرات دون اي عمليات عسكريه ان كان
هناك عمليه عسكريه فلتنتهي بسرعه بالسيطره
فقط
بان الكثيرين يتساءلون عن ما مدى مجاعه
هذه العمليه ولماذا دفع الروس بها كد عملي
الباص حتى يتحدث باقي سمات داخل الجيش
الروسي على كل شيء
الجدران
ارسل رساله للدكتور رمضان وغيرهم الذين
يتحدثون عن ذلك
الجنرال الشتاء كان مستخدم في وكان حافظه
بالنسبه للقوات السوفيتيه اثناء الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ضد الالمان اثناء توغل
الالمان في الشتاء 41 تجاه موسكو الذين لم
يكن له مجهزين بالوقود
الشتوي ولا باللبس الشتوي فلا داعي
لاستخدام هذا
اللفظ في ضمن الروس الذين يتقاتلون بعضهم
البعض الان احنا مجاهد
حضرتك ساكتفي بهذا القدر على انه يتابع
بقيه التطورات ولك في حلقات الاخرى شكرا
جزيلا لكما من موسكو تيمور ودار الخبير
فقطع الاعمال والعلاقات الدوليه وشكر كذلك
كيف اوراق رمضان رئيس
شكرا لكم